Hello everybo- What the f*ck?
Hello everybody, my name's Markiplier and welcome to the rubber band watermelon explosion challenge
where we're gonna be putting rubber bands around these tiny infinitesimal watermelons
because they're not in season
Infinitesimal, thank you
That's not really a word. Mark: Yes, it's a word!
Anyway, we're gonna be doing this, we're gonna be going up against Team Edge
We don't know how long this'll take
Gonna cuh
We don't know how long this is gonna take so we got a giant pile of about a couple thousand rubber bands here
And we're just gonna keep adding them onto these tiny melons and hope for the best
Three, two, one, go
Tiny melons
Just, all in the same spot
Ryan: We should all have one ready, so it should be like... Matt: I'll hold it, you guys. Ryan: Him, me, you
Matt: It's gonna blow up in our faces
Yeah
Matthias: Definitely. Mark: Probably
Ryan: Will it hurt?
Matthias: Yep. Mark: Probably. Probably kill us
Matthias: Dude. Dude, aim it away from us
Matt: am I gonna go blind?
Matthias: so they don't shoot off
Bryan: so, just sshhhh
Matthias: shush, shush, shush, shush
Bryan: why are you man-handling it so much? Matthias: why am I man-handling it? Hold it like a man
Oh my god
We got this
Matthias: ya cans on bleed
Matthias: We have... Bryan: wait... Matthias: hold it man!
Hold it like a man
Do that again
Bryan: *mumbles*
Mark: let's go as fast as we can
Mark: get it. Matt: uh
Bryan: do that again
Matt: keep goin, keep goin, keep goin
Matthias: we must win, it must happen
Bryan: yes
Mark: it's never gonna happen. Bryan: dude, I don't want the thing to blow up in my face
Matt: traffic's getting cut off
Matt: yeah I'm scared it's gonna blind me. Bryan: that's a lot of pressure
Mark: nah, it'll be fine, don't worry about it
Matthias: it will be fine. Bryan: six YouTubers lose their eyes
Mark: in a horrible watermelon explosion. Jfred: every single one of them
(laughter)
Matthias: a horrible watermelon...You guys are goin' slow so it doesn't explode on you
Mark: no
Ryan: that's not true
Mark: what exactly is Matt... Bryan: this is for the water...
Mark: Matt, you gotta take your turn quicker
Matt: I'm sorry, I'm scared
Matthias: no, I cannot do this. Bryan: this is potentially gonna hurt. If it really...I've seen some of these explode pretty good
Matt: really?
Matthias: well now you tell us
(laughter)
Matthias: whose idea was it...? Bryan: well it isn't called the watermelon explosion challenge for nothing
Matthias: I bet it's just gonna crush, it's just gonna implode
Mark: I'm starting to flinch away from my watermelon
Matthias: the safety goggles for sure. Matt: is the shape even changing? Mark: yes, it is actually
Matt: oh I feel it, no I feel it, I feel it. It's definitely. It's gonna blow my fingers off
Bryan: why are, why are your eyes closed?
Bryan: Matt's eyes are closed. Ryan: It's not like an actual explosion
Mark: the rubber bands turn into C4. Ryan: It's gonna blow my hands off. Matt: Dude, look at it
Matthias: dude, they might be catching up, man. Ours may be just not wanting to do it
Ryan: Matt! Matt: I'm scared, alright?
Ryan: your job is to hold the watermelon. Bryan (mocking): I'm scared, alright?
Jfred: the rubber band... Matt: oh I really see it changing shape
Bryan: oh we got it! Matthias: oh, oh! Bryan: we got it! Matthias: yes, yes!
(laughter) Bryan: woooohhh!
Mark: oh that's so cool
Matthias: yeah, the victory. Bryan: oh look at this
Mark: oh my god (laughing)
Mark: keep going, we gotta get ours, we gotta get ours to go
Matthias: victory tastes so good
Mark: I bet it doesn't, it doesn't sound like it does. Matt: I'm ready
Bryan: look at that thing. Look at it's blossoming
OOHHHH
(laughter)
Matt: oh, I'm scared now
(laughing) Bryan: what on Earth?
(laughing)
Bryan: that was right...I was holding it right when it did that. Matthias: you were like look at it, look at it blossoming
Matthias: cause it was just like
Jfred: it was blossomed all right
Bryan: I looked at it and it was like, huh, it looks like the top is like blossoming..boom
(laughter)
Matthias: and I really...wait, you guys are off camera doing that
Ryan: you're off camera. Bryan: come over here more this way guys
Mark: why are you eating their melon?
Matt: sorry. Jfred: should we help em or no? Mark: no, no, no, we got this. I wanna finish this strong
Mark: I want to see this thing explode
Matt: nope. Mark: oh, oh, oh it started bottom up
Matthias: flip it! Mark: AHH! Matthias: flip it man. Bryan: flip it
Mark: I don't want to hold that. Bryan: you got it
Jfred: take the rubber bands off. Bryan: you got it. Matthias: hold it you pansies
Bryan: hold it, keep going. Jfred: go, go, go, go. Mark: I'm gonna do one more
Mark: AAHH it's on
Matthias: yum
(laughter)
Ryan: I'm trying to.. Mark: it's gonna blow!
(laughter) Jfred: put three on at once! Mark: it looks like a face, just opening up there. Matthias: keep goin'
Matthias: dude, you're juicin' that watermelon, baby
Matthias: dude, there it goes, there it goes
Matthias: it's splitting down the side. Mark: I feel it
AAHHH OH (laughter) Bryan: look at it, a perfect ball
Mark: yeah! (laughter)
Matthias: a, a rubber band ball. Mark: oh my god, look at... Bryan: look how far this piece went
Mark: look at this thing
Mark: is this yours or mine? Matthias: oh I scooped out of it. Mark: oh ok
Mark: that's not... Matthias: I ate it like an animal. Mark: this is the one. Matthias: I ate it like an animal
Mark: holy shit, it's like a helmet
Mark: mmmm, that's bad. Matt: yeah, it's bad watermelon
Mark: alright, so thank you everybody so much for watching
We do have other watermelons, so check out Team Edge's channel to see if we did another version of this channel
Thanks again everyone. Oh wait... Ryan: good job
Mark: check out Team Edge, they're cool, we might have done another challenge. Actually we've done a whole bunch of challenges
so check out all the one's that we've done in the past, and the next one that's over there right now
Thanks again everybody. We'll see you in the next one.  Bye-bye
(outtro music)